thank you so this is single page apps
what an API developer should know I am
here to bring you a message from
front-end land that things are different
here I spent over 10 years as a back-end
developer and about eight months this
year as a manager for a front-end
engineering team building an angular app
there were a lot of things that I had to
wrap my head around in order to be able
to successfully design a product that I
think API developers should know more
widely so that's what this talk is about
so you should listen to this talk if
you're a builder of particularly read
and write api's or api's which power
client applications so why should you
learn more about s pas as an API
developer the first topic is
architecture another one is security and
there are some particular challenges
around teams and how you do your
engineering process and your
communication so we'll talk a bit about
those and of course your choice of stack
do you want to be developing a single
page app is it the right choice for you
so I'd like to do a quick couple of
polls can you raise your hand if you've
ever developed a single page app okay I
think we have about four people all
right now I'd like everybody to raise
their hand okay
so leave your hand up if you've ever
written an API okay
leave your hand up if you've ever
written an API that backs a single page
app
okay down to maybe ten people you've
written an API that backs a single page
app that has user login functionality
okay I think we have two three oh and a
fourth over there all right has anybody
written an API platform that backs
multiple different single page apps with
user logins yeah great awesome we got a
couple of pros over there all right so
you guys probably already know what I'm
gonna talk about but we'll go on so as I
already mentioned we're gonna talk about
single page app architecture a little
overview for those of you who are less
familiar we're gonna talk about security
state management in your application
what the what it really means that a
single page app is static some options
for backends to single page apps and
then finish up with the whole why I care
about this
so for architecture it's hard to be a
developer these days and not have heard
of angular view react or ember those are
really the big single page app
frameworks these are mostly pretty
similar although view and react offer
some server-side rendering or isomorphic
JavaScript support that muddies the
water a bit but for the most part these
are similar so if we talk about more
let's say traditional app development
server-side rendering versus client-side
rendering that's really the highest
level difference that you need to worry
about whether your server is prepping
the HTML and sending it out to the
client on every request or whether
that's kind of happening client-side so
a single page app
the very first request brings down the
bundle of HTML CSS and JavaScript and
then pretty much all your subsequent
requests are gonna be just data only and
done via API is on the back end and
we'll see this illustrated in the next
slide so the top you have the
traditional page lifecycle requesting
requests coming in on the left from the
client request goes to the server server
sends back HTML you have another request
this time it's a forum post server sends
back HTML so below that you have the
single page app lifecycle request comes
in from the client on the Left hits the
server sends back HTML but that's really
the big bundle of the single page app
being downloaded the first time and then
another request that one is going to be
ajax coming out of the single page app
and json coming back so one key part of
really understanding and coming to grips
with how different single page apps are
is that you can deploy them entirely
statically in an s3 bucket when i was
working on a project with a single page
app this was one of the hardest things
for other developers to understand i had
to spend a lot of time explaining to our
DevOps team why we didn't need any you
know really complicated continuous
deployment pipelines or monitoring
because our code was going to be in an
s3 bucket but it also had ramifications
for sort of how we thought about how we
did security how certain middleware
layers were going to make sure that
people were passing the right security
tokens through and so on and I'll be
elaborating on the ramifications of this
but for the rest of the talk
so a standard single page app only has a
single route on the server and I think
my slides a little bit out of order so
your single page app is just probably
hosted at your root domain name whatever
your site comm is and that's the place
where a client's browser request is
going to go and download the bundle of
your single page app but in it the the
telltale sign of a single page app is
usually the hash tag in the URL so the
hash tag is the indication that
JavaScript is doing the routing and
essentially building up the pages for
everything after that so now let's talk
a bit about security so you can never
trust your client code there's there's
really no way
once that single page app bundle goes
out to the world that you can make sure
that nobody has tampered with the code
so that's the most important point here
and then what that means for API
developers is that you're responsible
for security in the API all of the
authentication actually belongs to the
user you can't keep secrets in your in a
single page app the users own knowledge
of their username and password are
basically all you get in terms of
security so user will enter their
username and password after they are
authenticated you they'll get a security
session token and then that's going to
be what's passed back to your API in
most situations
so your API in this case is also
responsible for authorization you can
only trust the user you can't trust the
client you can't trust the session key
either for authorization because there
are things that can happen which I'll
talk about in a second so your API
that's backing a single page app always
needs to double check permissions
stating this another way sessions
permissions belong to the user object
and don't rely on just session keys so
you want to authorize in real time for
anything that needs elevated permissions
in your back-end or does destructive
actions things can happen in real time
that make sessions or permissions
invalid such as a user's account
entering fraud status or somebody making
an attempt to break into a you know too
many failed password attempts or
something on their account so your API
needs to always be checking so this is a
one of the trickiest things so if you
are building an API platform it's
probably going to have multiple clients
access it so say you have different
clients to service different industry
verticals you know one could be you know
since we're a couple of once a once
we're banking one is for the DMV a given
user can authorize a client on their
account you know using three-legged
OAuth but a malicious user can abuse
those privileges to perform actions that
are not supposed to happen from that
client how do you differentiate the
users and their from
per client if you can't trust the client
one option is forcing multiple user
accounts for different permissions so
you push it back to the user they have
to have a different set of credentials
but that kind of defeats the purpose of
your identity platform I don't have a
great answer to this it's it's just kind
of a problem in single page a planned a
final note on single page app security
in addition to the users off token your
API needs to support xsrf tokens to
prevent against cross-site scripting
attacks this is something people often
overlook as well and I found this great
quote from a really good article on
single page apps and why they need
cross-site scripting protections
so if tokens aren't enough why do so
many public API is only provide
token-based authentication probably
because the primary use case for these
API is isn't to be consumed directly by
a JavaScript client in a web browser are
you sure your apps are so secure
okay so I'd like to talk a little bit
about state your API is probably not a
museum although I have worked on many a
read-only API myself having been in the
open government space a lot of apps that
just serve up kind of canonical data are
you know read-only api's so this was
kind of an attitude that I had brought
to the work but most likely if you're
interested in this talk your API is more
like a bazaar
it needs to be able to save state and
possibly transactional histories maybe
have object versioning audit logs etc
another quick poll
raise your hand if you develop read-only
api's nobody ok good so something that
people often struggle with in this sort
of development is that client state of
course can't persist across sessions or
devices it's kind of a sort of a thing
to think about but it gets overlooked
occasionally especially when the API
team and the front-end team er have
competing priorities and you know maybe
there's a new piece of data you need to
save and the API doesn't have the
capability to save it yet so there are
considerations around that and just to
say again your your your API is really
not a museum you need to think carefully
about how client interactions should or
should not change your core data a lot
of times API developers have these sort
of grand ideas about how their data
schema works and
what their REST API structure is like
but they're not as prepared to do things
like represent clients state in their
API and you might need to think about
how you do that in other models or other
micro services etc once you have a
client-side single page app and play UX
really becomes important to how you
think about the persistence and refresh
of data you need to consider what data
may change in your API that the user
needs to know about or the app needs to
respond to how will the user get that
data unless you're implementing
WebSockets updates will be based on
polling or strategically timed refreshes
some data can be fetched and persisted
at login others with each page load and
others may need to be after more
granular interactions by the user this
is also another hard thing for API
developers to understand which is that
modern jas frameworks are built on the
idea that the client app is independent
this is especially true under the react
and redux or rxjs model but those single
page apps are really implementing an
independent datastore and data model
inside their own application
so what does that mean well the api's
data model may be similar to but not
identical to what the client needs as a
result getting data
getting data out of the API is easy but
getting it back in will often be harder
because objects that are transformed for
displayed in the client will need to be
transformed back or untransformed to be
persisted back into the API and what
that means for your development team is
that every time a schema of X changes in
your API Y in the client may need to
change its schema as well so a tip here
is to really talk to your front-end or
edge API developers here because their
experience building your data model into
a client can inform a better API design
so the upshot of being static what does
it all mean so at this point of the talk
I want to look at the ramifications of
all these things just to review a URL
refers to the whole of a single page app
any URL referring to something inside
the app beyond the front page is called
a deep link deep linking is possible but
often tricky or annoying to implement
for the front-end devs because single
page apps are often built for people to
come sort of in the front door of the
application single page apps are static
plus logic and Ajax so that means that
your API layer is now exposed to the
world your API can't hide behind
server-side rendering like it did with
with server-side application development
another thing is that all of your
experiences for the client must be baked
into it in the first place
you can't really push a new experience
or flow to the user based on data
circumstance or state it has to be there
from the beginning and by extension of
that sensitive data must be preserved in
the API datum you might not think of as
sensitive but which is data which a
given user might not be privy to needs
to be held on the server side so an
example of that might be things were on
terms and conditions or certain even
error states you might think that it's
simple just to code all your error
states into your application but you you
might not want to reveal all of your
possible error states to the world so
this harkens back to the security
portion of this talk separating business
logic and all possible permutations of
that as well as sensitive data requires
a different way of thinking than you may
be used to so there are some back-end
solutions that can help smooth some of
these difficulties over pretty popular
one is writing edge api's I mentioned
exposing your API to the world well an
edge layer sits in front of your key ap
is and what it will do is expose proxy
and orchestrate your API endpoints so if
there's particular you know REST API
resources that may be very pure for
instance so you have related resources
there may be a number of API calls that
need to be made in all at once in order
to
a particular page of a single page at an
edge API can kind of create a shortcut
for you to be able to pull all the data
that you need in in one view at one time
edge api's can also hold credentials for
specific clients all they need to be
careful with this or other API is that
you don't own within your same
enterprise or externally and then the
reason I said be careful about specific
clients is that it's still possible for
a rogue client to use an edge beyond its
intended purpose so you have to be
careful about that another thing which
muddies the single page app waters a
little bit is that some of the other
frameworks like view and react to
support a form of server-side rendering
they help with search engine
optimization some performance issues on
the other hand they don't really help
with the security concerns that I've
outlined nor with the state issues so
why should you bother to understand all
of this well first of all if you need to
make architectural decisions knowing
better how single page apps works helps
you select your stack so determine your
overall architecture determine your API
is request and schema architecture that
helps us determine your authentication
your security and you should really know
what you're building it's important when
you're working with single page apps for
your API team to kind of have some
guiding principles figure it out
beforehand or how you want things to
work have your team live by them
though iterating is needed so some
questions you want to consider are which
parts of your API are general-purpose
the flip side of that is which ones are
tailored to a given client experience
where do those two things overlap and
what data do you need to protect another
concern is API versioning when you're
building an API to a client coupling
between the API and the client can
become very tight API versioning of
course is kind of a contentious topic
versioning and headers versus URLs is
something a certain subset of devs likes
to argue about I would propose that for
a maximum agility and least code debt
and not having to support multiple
versions in both back-end and client
code that you consider an additive only
approach sort of like when you're
designing a good database migration if
you're familiar with those so backwards
and compatible changes must be made to
new endpoints and old endpoints must
only be removed if no one is using them
anymore
and in case I didn't harp on it enough
just a reminder that we really have to
understand how single page apps function
in order to securely properly secure our
apps I have a suspicion that the world
is probably full of insecure single page
apps and consequently insecure api's so
some things that kind of happen when
you're developing single page apps it's
really easy for your teams to fall into
functional silos because of the the
extent to which the stack is separated
so I'd like to propose some
considerations to counteract functional
silos
I said the word client a bunch in this
talk and I was using it in the computing
sense of a piece of software which
accesses a server but I'd like to
propose an alternate way to think about
that the front end team is your client
their needs will drive much of what you
build listen to them very carefully if
you have a front-end lead they may be
your de-facto Solutions Architect this
was actually the role that I played on
this team because the person who needs
everything and the client to work also
needs everything all the way through to
the backend to work trying to focus your
communication around verticals so when
you fall into functional silos
they're probably horizontal silos by
team and by front-end back-end stack in
that case it becomes more important to
communicate around features so try to
direct your teams around understanding
really front to back how what they're
building is going to work and pictures
and diagrams interaction models with
single page apps tend to be really
complicated at times draw sequence
diagrams they really really help so hey
API developers yes this talk is about
you it's about all of us working better
together
you should understand API eight excuse
me single page apps for making better
architectural decisions having better
security better state management and
better engineering process management
and thank you and happy building
[Applause]
also my team is hiring see any questions
[Music]
I was wondering if you could talk about
some of the trade-offs between a single
page application and just our
traditional rendering application for
some sort of really data-driven like
application that you're gonna construct
yeah well you know I think some things
you need to think about are again having
UX drive some of those decisions for
something that you need to be truly
real-time responsive interactive a
single page app may be a great way to go
but I personally I think that the world
has kind of rushed a little bit too much
in that direction for data heavy
applications I think it's it's it's good
to render things server-side and then
provide Ajax to speed up certain
interactions yeah okay that's it can we
give a big round of applause then -
speaker thank you